grab right okay don't come in half fast
like that
[Music]
stand up
turn o watch your
range don't don't pull them down
okay that's not
it waight on your hands
[Music]
the
what the
heck he
be
more you just go James
watch your ch
to go full
tight not here
see now your head is
rolling hit it choke it Wist it feet go
forward bend her over at her waist
deconstruct her
[Music]
Center not leave
her
[Music]
deconstruct that's
nothing take her face
[Music]
part this time
drop how about you
[Music]
so this hand has
thew not
P it just
disappears
relaxation so again try not to do the
obious take away the
disagreement the extension
disappears he lowers
him then put your weight in your
hands and blend for the
opening disappear wait
[Music]
opening
disappear wait
opening resist
obvious okay
[Music]
it's not the obvious one of full of
backwards because that would
be an antagonistic energy he's going
that way and you're going to pull this
way see that's not
I then if you bend him over at the
waist right you don't have his base
deconstructed you have to kind of
wave
through his Center
out
just pull
down if you're not going down if you're
going down on one knee right if you're
if you're we're doing a technique and
you're supposed to drop down it's one
and or two things one you're phys
physically unfit your legs are too weak
your muscles are too tight you can't do
it and or two you're too afraid you're
afraid you're going to hurt yourself and
that frag that frag fragility is that
the word okay that
fragility is in you at all times it's
just coming to the surface now but
you're walking around with it all day
long in all your work in all your
relationships and you are constantly on
guard you are constantly in a defensive
mode so you're either stressed out
anxious or you're disengaging you're
avoiding you're doing it all the time
okay so you need to work on your body so
that this is it's just that I open my
legs and my Center drops it's a pure
relaxation move I'm not I'm not doing
anything I just
open I'm not slamming My Knees Down
okay let's go do the technique
right okay I could easily Chuck him
right okay but watch what I'm going to
do I'm going to go around his
head see that there's no energy there's
no there's no resistance to his
Mas that's why I move over here
I go around
it so cuz you're cuz you're spinning him
forward and his ass your back okay is
you just turning him on his foot you
have to
take his face away did you feel that
difference you're going to P him on your
foot on his foot it's not the
technique you have to take his face
away okay TR again do you understand the
concept of not being stuck on throwing
the person you're working with but
instead working on the
form your body alignment your structure
your posture your
breathing your timing your
mind okay all these things your
extension your
palm right your palm positioning your
finger positioning your chin positioning
working on all of that and thereby
coincidentally not
even in terms of consequence a
coincidence they get
thrown
harder that's how you train K don't try
and throw prisilla hard don't try and
throw Ronan hard no whoever you're with
you're trying to find the form and
you're trying to embody the
form you're taking their individuality
the particularity of that given rep rep
and you're recalculating it with you
with your own particularity to find the
form that's
K that's what you're supposed to be
doing but if you're tempted and you fall
prey to the temptation of throwing
Priscilla hard throwing Ronan
hard you're not going to learn the art
you're just going to throw Priscilla
hard you're just going to throw Ronan
hard and that's
it and that means nothing
so don't train that way don't train for
nothing find the
form is that
clear and make it
clear make it clear if you believe in
it right and you're not living
it it's
dishonest it's dis you're lying to
yourself you're lying your partners
you're lying to your
teachers break that cycle truly accept
it truly and do nothing else that's the
diligence you need that's the dedication
that's the
discipline every UK is a Temptation
every UK is a
choice and by choosing the right one
right eating the right
wolf right you increase the validity the
authenticity of your practice but if
with every UK and every rep you keep
feeding the wrong
wolf you have an inauthentic
practice think of each UK think of each
rep as boths opportunity to Dam yourself
or to save
yourself those two have to be presented
simultaneously for you to actually
cultivate according to according to
virtues right if one's not
there right what does it mean chose
that's
ridiculous it's like the the saying
about pacifism it's not pacifism if you
couldn't have kicked the out of
that
person right that's not
pacifism that's just I'm too weak to
have the other op that's all it is it's
just weakness so the choice has to be
presented simultaneous simultaneously
and you have to be diligent enough to
always choose correctly and not choose
the wrong one the weak
one the one that leads
nowhere and see your whole practice on
the map that way whomever I'm with
whenever I'm with each rep is like that
I never fall to the temptation of just
throwing this person hard but I'm doing
k Ona the goal the only goal is to find
the form and embody the form in the
particularity of this given rep that's
what I try to do and then you'll find
wow this H is flying all over the place
so is this UK so is that UK and every
rep with UK is flying all over the place
now you're learning the
art now you're not just playing ik